the big news about you Kim
kardashian-west wants to become a lawyer
yes that's a good thing
aspiring lawyer Kim Kardashian is
working to free kevin cooper a man
sentenced and sent to death row for the
murder of four people in the 1980s on
friday kardashian shared this pic on
twitter writing quote i had an emotional
meeting with kevin cooper yesterday at
San Quentin's death row I found him to
be thoughtful and honest and I believe
he is innocent of the crimes for which
she was convicted she added I am hopeful
that Kevin will be exonerated since DNA
testing has now been ordered on Kevin's
case now Mary Ann Hughes the mother of
one of his alleged victims is speaking
out telling TMZ she is disgusted by the
reality stars recent meeting with Cooper
quote it makes me feel sick to my
stomach and I pity her for what she's
doing to us there's nothing to justify
what she's doing to us the immense pain
she is causing us Hughes added that Kim
quote obviously has not read all of the
actual evidence she has bought into
half-truths perpetrated by the defense
if she actually sat down and read the
transcripts of all the trials and
appeals she would be sick to her stomach
to be in the same room with him I really
had no idea how broken the system is and
I just figured if I know more about the
system I can do more for the system and
that's just the type of person that I am
Kardashian announced her plan to study
for the bar exam after successfully
working to free Alice Marie Johnson a 63
year old who had been serving a life
sentence for a first-time nonviolent
drug offense on this journey of getting
Alice out I have learned so much about
criminal justice
and really how messed up our system is
in the April issue of Vogue she
explained quote I just felt like I
wanted to be able to fight for people
who have paid their dues to society
in May CNN reported that Kardashian had
been instrumental in helping freeze 17
first-time nonviolent drug offenders who
were serving life sentences
Britney K Barnett Kim's personal
attorney explained quote we've been
going around the country in courtrooms
and asking judges to release these
inmates Kim has provided financial
support to cover legal fees so that we
can travel the country she is truly
dedicated to the issue
[Music]